getting rid of old leaves providing soil
for new crops South African mark me berg
is on a green mission as part of a
nationwide initiative mark is showing
his community how to grow their own
vegetables I think it makes me really
passionate about what I'm doing is we're
able to equip people with the skill that
offers intangible a tangible difference
and it's something that's not going to
take me a year two years within a few
weeks you can start eating out of your
garden the project is located in
mitchells plain a low-income area of
Cape Town it was established as a so
called colored Township during the
apartheid era today it's notorious for
gang violence and drug abuse working
here has its own challenges apart from
funding issues mark and his colleagues
regularly deal with another problem so
we suffer from a lot of vandalism
robbery so we get broken into so for
instance over the last holiday period
all our tools got stolen mark wants to
keep the youth of mitchell's plain away
from crime everyday he teaches the
pupils from the adjacent primary school
how to garden
being on the school it allows us to do
connect kids again with a natural
environment so the sowing of seeds the
planting out of seedlings are working in
the garden is as making or creating
awareness within the kids themselves of
the natural world twelve-year-old Tamia
is one of them I like gardening because
it keeps me calm and every but the
project is not only aimed at kids
through his food freedom initiative mark
encourages community members to turn
their back yards into urban gardens
mitchell's plain resident Edgar quarries
read about the initiative in the local
newspaper the long time gardener
benefits from the project he gets seeds
and compost and shares his produce with
others the lady upstairs up the road the
neighbor she's for fun of a cocktail and
she don't buy a coat anymore I supply
her with a cake self-sustainability
skills development a connection to the
environment that's what Mark seeks to
promote thus far more than 170 local
families have started an urban garden
look at all the spices that one is able
to see that I'm not being used those are
the pieces of land that need to be
cultivated we could be growing food
because it's there I just needs to be
expanded a lot more but it's definitely
there Mark's ambitious goal a garden in
every backyard